let's keep going back to the 80s so is
that pretty much all we know about what
happened with them in the 80s or with
the financial Bounty Hunter stuff well
the other thing is too right so you know
Bill Casey had this relationship with
bear Stearns he's CIA director Epstein
leaves and then he teams up with someone
like Adnan khashoggi and then at the
around the same time other two other
people take on Adam ashoki as clients
Robert Keith Gray who worked on very
closely with Bill Casey on the Reagan
campaign and Roy Cohn the lawyer who
also worked very closely
um with Bill Casey on the Reagan
campaign and both and as I note in
volume one of my book both of those men
have very extensive ties to sexual
blackmail Roy Cohen does yeah oh yeah
was a lawyer for a lot of mobsters for
many of them yes and many powerful
people in New York he was the guy you
got when you know you needed somebody to
take care of you now the the Roy is Roy
Cohen's story at all linked to Jay Edgar
Hoover or no is there any connection
between yeah I mean I I write about it
pretty extensively they were very close
and you know even Roy cohn's uh probably
one of his best known biographers
Nicholas von Hoffman that wrote citizen
cone uh just couldn't it really even
explain why the official story of J
Edgar Hoover and Roy cohn's meeting uh
he just found it very odd because it
it's so it was so uncommon at that time
for someone to just Waltz in to Jay Jay
Edgar Hoover's office and have that kind
of access to him uh right away but
there's been several
um
um authors and well I document this all
in volume one pretty extensively uh that
that point to there having been some
sort of relationship previously that
they had met previously through through
some sort of um weird sexual it seems to
have been a sexual blackmail operation
and Roy Cohn later apparently admitted
this to an NYPD uh detective there was
some sort of sexual blackmail thing
going on that entrapped J Edgar Hoover
and Roy Cohn participated not
necessarily in entrapping J Edgar Hoover
but they had these sex parties right and
so J Edgar Hoover was seen at these Roy
Cohn was seen as these in a guy that was
close to both Hoover and Cohn Louis
Rosensteel who was a liquor Baron of
that particular area was also sort of in
the same same circuit and it it's
alleged that this all took place at the
Plaza Hotel it's important to say this
Roku while you're going through this
everything that you write about is
primary sources right it's not for the
most part you're going through primary
sources or you know so in the case of
this a lot of it comes from books
different books written by people that
are sourced that way from interviews and
things like that
um but yeah I mean I I anyone that looks
in the book and goes through the
footnotes of what I write about is going
to find like very high quality sourcing
sure so
so you're not saying Roy Cohen was
involved in the sexual blackmail against
Jay Edgar Hoover is why you know the mob
was able to say so Roy wasn't involved
at all to Corner Jay Edgar Hoover so he
can help them out that was not actually
not necessarily but they seemed to have
been in this they attended these same
sex parties that the mob was apparently
using to Blackmail people and when Roy
Cohn admitted his involved he uh
apparently admitted to this NYPD by
Squad detective
um that he was involved in these kind of
operations but that he only did it
because he had been entrapped uh
originally so this NYPD detective had
like a he when I interviewed him he
expressed us like some sympathy towards
come like he felt bad for him but Khan
did this stuff because he was apparently
entrapped at some point and you know you
have to keep in mind this is a period of
time when it's very difficult to be a
gay man in DC
so you know a lot of this stuff is sort
of like underground and you know it if
it were to come out that they were
homosexual it could have ended their
political careers both of them him and
Jade group absolutely why the blackmail
was so effective right absolutely period
And by the way even Roy Cohen's
assistant who was with him they call him
he was his lover he died in 1984 from
AIDS that's Roy Cohen's assistant who
died in 1984 from AIDS and that's the
AIDS pandemic where you know everybody
was talking about raccoon also died for
me you're right I know but it you know
the point being is his assistant died
from it and then boom the same thing
happened the stories with J Edgar Hoover
he was the director of the CIA FBI I'm
sorry FBI the story is about
cross-dressing and high heels how how
much truth is is in that okay so uh
there's a there's a couple different
sources from that so one is Susan
Rosensteel or I think that's her name if
I'm not mistaken it's Louis rosensteel's
fourth wife as a source for that and
then um there was a separate sort there
there were two or three separate sources
on related to Susan Rosensteel that
corroborated that claim so when there's
that many sources it's almost like when
there's smoke there's fire how much well
you know it's um
um when it's corroborated I mean I I
feel like then it's possible to report
it I mean people can make their own
conclusions I mean there's some people I
think that have a very vested image and
the the image of Hoover that we're all
old so like you know there'll be people
it doesn't matter how much you
corroborated there'll be people who
won't do you believe that Pat no what
about J Edgar Hoover and cross-dressing
and if I'm going to put odds nothing is
100 because I wasn't there to witness it
while he was getting it on but I would
say 90 oh is that high I think so I
think I don't think it's I don't think
it's a issue anymore his secret life
with like Clyde Tolson and you know that
he had a he was a homosexual and all of
this is well known and there's even been
like Bill Clinton's speeches from the
90s where he sort of references that
about J Edgar Hoover and everyone laughs
in the room right so like you know there
may be some stuff that isn't known
necessarily to the American public but
like in these Elite circles and DC you
know the stuff gets out right so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]